the basic premise of the show is that
rip hunter who's a time traveler comes
from the future and gathers this group
of heroes and villains for a mission the
future depends on that
part of the fun of the show is watching
all these different personalities try to
learn how to work together it will exist
connected to the flash in the air our
universe but if you take it out
separately it has to exist in of itself
we're designing a 13-episode first
season and the intention is to do a big
13 hour long mega movie how's it feel to
be a good guy doesn't pay as well people
are really excited for another female
character they're excited to see strong
female characters it's a group of
superheroes and they're dealing with
stuff that it's pretty epic visual
effects would be at the same standard of
all of our shows that would be both a
mixture of high level stunt work and
features stunt work mixed with high
level visual effects as big as the other
two shows are as arrow and flash art we
have to go even bigger
arrow is all about saving Starling city
and flash is all about saving Central
City this is the first show that we're
doing that's all about saving the world
it's gonna be exciting it's going to be
thrilling it's gonna be funny it's going
to look huge
hey youtubers it's Charlie so time to
talk about legends of tomorrow at Comic
Con DC and Warner Brothers are doing
their big super panel but they're doing
some special legends of tomorrow and
Supergirl stuff just because those are
the new shows most of the big cast is
gonna be there at least Victor Garber
don't know about Robbie Amell that's
really like the big question of the hour
because look at this promo image they
just revealed it's a new firestorm
costume but this could be Jay Jackson's
firestorm he could secretly be Jason
rush like a recast version of the
character I know a lot of you are
wondering because cuz they already had
Jason rush on the show they could have
just recast that role it happens all the
time I'm not expecting him to be cyborg
it just says in his character bio that
he's a former athlete that's working in
an auto body shop I think they want you
to think that it might be a cyborg but
really I think that it's J Jackson and
the reason is is because they've been so
mysterious about what's going on with
Robbie Amell and firestorm so here just
like a couple big things that they could
announce at that panel one they could
announce who J Jackson's character is
two they could announce who they've cast
as Vandal Savage because we don't know
who that is yet and three they could
explain how the show is gonna tie in
with arrow in the flash specifically we
know that there's gonna be some villain
crossover because Grant Gustin said and
in the first episode of the flash season
2 we learn who the villain was really
quickly like he would he would arise out
of that big [ __ ] storm in the sky and it
would crossover with legends of tomorrow
so we know that crossovers will not be
limited to the hero characters we're
gonna see the big bad from the flash go
to legend to tomorrow
that doesn't necessarily mean that it's
Vandal Savage but it could be he could
be the big bad on the flash in case you
missed the announcement though Vandal
Savage is the big bad on legends of
tomorrow that's a TV show I know some
people are confused as to whether or not
it's a movie or a TV show it's a 13
episode TV show the narrative structure
shares a little bit more in common with
with serialized shows like daredevil on
Netflix like you're meant to consume
them as one giant movie Marc Guggenheim
Andrew Kreisberg although all the
producers are just calling it like a 13
hour mega blockbuster movie given that
there's going to be so much crossover
between all three of these shows I
definitely think that you guys should
watch arrow flash and legends of
tomorrow
now legends of tomorrow won't air till
2016 is basically going to start in
January whenever
arrow and flash comeback that's actually
something that I'm really hoping they
announce at comic-con what day it's
gonna premiere and what day during the
week that it's gonna air on unless they
say otherwise I'm just gonna assume for
practical purposes they're gonna air it
on a different night from Supergirl
flash and arrow that means it have to be
on Thursday or Friday and logically I
think Thursday would be the right pick
but but the problem is is the CW already
has shows on that night so so we'll see
it could always be a Sunday show one of
the coolest things that they've said
about it recently is that all the heroes
won't necessarily stick to the plan as
they're jumping around in time trying to
fight FanDuel savage they'll try to use
time travel to their own benefit you
have to remember that even though this
is kind of like TV Justice League this
isn't the Justice League and they're not
like in their final boss form they're
still baking in the oven so they're
gonna make a lot of derps especially
when they have the power of time travel
remember that speech the Captain Cold
gave to bear at the end of season one
when he double-crossed him I'm a
criminal I hurt people so yeah as much
as he's gonna be an antihero during
legends of tomorrow I think that he's
definitely gonna try and misuse time
travel that that's really weird like rip
hunter comes in he's the person that's
in charge of fixing all that I can see
it now Captain Cold tries to steal rip
hunters time machine rip hunter goes
crazy on him rip hunters actually leave
them pretty dark in the comics before
Booster Gold has always been like a
fairly you know funny light character
rip hunter is like the darker version of
that and he's actually Booster Gold son
for people that haven't read the comics
but they'll be telling you a whole bunch
of other stories inside this Vandal
Savage story the only other thing that's
been confirmed about it is that in the
first episode of the flash season 2
firestorm will still be fused Robbie
Amell and Victor Garber will still be
firestorm together Victor Garber just
said that after that who knows meaning
that you know presumably something is
going to happen during the flash
premiere that will answer the question
as to whether or not Rob emails on
legends of tomorrow they're really two
big things they could do with the
firestorm character one they could make
it possible for them to separate and
form firestorm on their own instead of
needing two people or two they could
kill Ronnie Raymond both of those things
have happened in the comics like he's
been killed off and brought back that
was before the new 52 reboot he came
back during blackest night and then he
came back for real in the more recent
comics Jason Rusch and Ronnie Raymond
both become firestorm so that they can
activate the matrix on their own they
to form together but when they do it
forms this giant transformer combiner
firestorm just looking at the way the
producers and the castes are talking
about it what I think happened is that
Robbie Amell film career is just taking
off so they used it as an opportunity to
tell a really interesting firestorm
story without completely fridging Ronnie
Raymond's character just remember
there's no such thing as true death in
the comic book world especially in the
arrowverse usually the reason you don't
see actors come back like Huntress the
break the reason we haven't seen her
come back it's just because she's too
busy so even if Ronnie Raymond does
leave the show it'll only be temporary
like he'll still be involved with them
Robbie Amell is a totally awesome dude
so he's always gonna come back but think
about how his departure might open the
door for Caitlin snow to become killer
frost that's a bit of an
oversimplification I mean it'll be much
more dynamic than that but but just
think about how all those things line up
so I would say you know of all the
things that I think the dagur announced
at Comic Con the least likely would be
what's going on with Jay Jackson's
character that feels like something they
would save for that first episode like
if you know boom big spectacle surprise
so here's my big question for you guys
what are you hoping that they announce
about legends of tomorrow at comic-con
like who the actors are who Vandal
Savage is or do you think that they're
gonna show a new trailer the only reason
I don't think that they're gonna show a
new trailer they might show a little bit
more footage but not like a full-blown
trailer is because they've just started
to shoot so they probably not have
enough footage yet usually Comic Con
happens at the end of July so by that
time they've had a couple weeks to shoot
so they have something to show off the
footage that they've already aired for
legends of tomorrow like the the first
look trailer that they aired a couple
months ago that was actually just a
promo that they shot for the up fronts
it was literally a week of them just
shooting just that footage they weren't
shooting in actual episodes so don't be
surprised if that footage does not end
up in the first episode of legends of
tomorrow it's not exactly a Hollywood
secret but usually marketing departments
are the ones that cut trailers and
they'll ask directors as they can you
get me these specific lines for the
trailer even if the director never
intends to put them in the movie the
actual movie so if you ever wondered why
you saw something in a trailer but
didn't see it in the movie that's why so
really important details about the
actual panel the DC TV panel is
happening at 8 o'clock p.m. on Saturday
night legends of tomorrow is going to be
part of that big DC super panel they're
going to do like a mass
of Q&A for all the shows you know
probably back to back to back I have a
scheduling conflict during then but I'm
gonna try and make it even if I can't
I'll still do a video for all the stuff
that they announce at it Saturday night
is just like the craziest time at
comic-con there is the scheduling is a
little bit nicer this year because last
year the Marvel panel was at the end of
the night so Hall H was a log jam all
day what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna start
the new round of the DC giveaway in this
video so all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment but when we do get to comic-con
what I'm gonna do is I'll just update
everyone on my schedule on Twitter and
Facebook there are links in the
description for that so if you're not
sure when certain videos are gonna post
like certain panels and in footage that
I'm getting just take my Twitter and
Facebook internet is really bad at Comic
Con so Twitter and Facebook are just
like the easy places for me to get
messages out if you do have any special
requests for stuff next week just be
sure to leave them in the comments so
while you guys wait for my next Comic
Con preview you can click here for all
my legends of tomorrow videos and you
can click here to learn all about killer
frost on the flash thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight